The Primavera by Botticelli, symbol of the Renaissance.
Florence was quick to welcome Greek scholars fleeing Constantinople now in Turkish hands.
They along with the rapid development of the printing industry helped spread humanistic
ideas.
What was humanism?
It was the resurrection of the old text, the only accepted culture besides theology, but
it was also a desire for independence, human perfection, individualism.
Pythagoras' work was brought back to life, man the measure of all things.
The idea that man could control his fate.
century before Boccaccio and Petrarch had paved the way by preaching the joys of life while the
great Dante was still deep in the dark ages Giotto painted living men Donatello dare to portray the
naked human figure hello my friend that's for me here you go I'll see you soon might as well
15th century Florence has often been compared to the Athens of Pericles time there's no doubt that
that not for 20 centuries had the world been treated to such a galaxy of stars.
1469, Lorenzo de' Medici rules Florence.
The great humanist Ficino speaks of Plato,
considered as a god by many religious sects.
In the studio of Verrocchio,
renowned sculptor and painter young Leonardo da Vinci
is just beginning his apprenticeship.
He is learning how to sculpt stone,
to melt bronze,
to build roads to fortify cities,
and to paint.
Bad.
Three years have gone by.
Ah, this boy's not bad.
Stucked by his pupil's beauty, Verrocchio makes a decision.
His David will have young Leonardo's face.
He looks to play in the city, Volterra refuses to come to terms.
Alum is an astringent necessary for the treatment of cloth.
A bit here.
What a fine kettle of fish.
Hello.
We'll just have to find a new source of alum to treat our cloth, and quick.
Why not see your console? Come on.
After a day of work in Verrocchio's studio, young Leonardo goes home.
Preasting no time to eat, he starts work right away.
For he's bound and determined to learn everything and understand it.
He will pursue his inspirations far into the night.
He's you there, you and you.
Quattrocento also knew 7,000 revolts, revolutions and wars, civil and otherwise.
As for assassinations, well, frankly, there were too many to count.
He's a man of his word. I don't think he'll make things difficult for us.
He's quite aware that our corporation of drapers cannot function under such unfavorable conditions.
Should he refuse to deliver the products we must have for production, we'll have to set out to look for them ourselves.
Me, you know me, I'm for roughing up this guy.
But you think he might get a little offended?
We think he's too important. Maybe we should just skip the subject. Maybe that's best.
Well, my good friend, I don't agree with you in this matter.
I ask you to trust me. This fellow knows what he's after.
Do the work.
Now look here, sir. We pay all that we owe.
After all, it's beyond me why the authorities won't defend and protect the interests of our corporation.
Don't you agree?
Why, yes.
But I ask for nothing more than to help you.
Ah.
I'm here to defend our profession.
You can believe me, you'll get satisfaction.
I will personally manage the doctor myself.
No, believe me, we'll fix all this, and Lorenzo de' Medici will do justice by your demands.
Oh, now see what I mean?
The city of Volterra refuses delivery of alum. Without alum, nothing could be done.
Obviously, we'll just have to get it for ourselves.
No sooner said than done.
The satisfaction of both parties. Lorenzo de' Medici didn't take no for an answer.
You, Leonardo, will finish the left angel.
Helmed by his pupil's talent, Verrocchio renounced painting, and from then on did nothing but sculpture.
Leonardo was ashamed of the thought of hurting his beloved master.
None of his own sculptures would ever reach completion.
Was this a coincidence or a kind of self-punch?
Three to two, huh?
One day, while Lorenzo de' Medici and his brother Julian were attending Mass,
their success, the conspirators hurried to the Lord's Palace,
only to find 64th's plot against the Medicis was a most miserable failure.
All this profoundly affected the young Leonardo,
who finished his sketch of one of the culprits, Bernardo Bandini,
and then went to Santa Croce Church to study some of Giotto's work.
Three to two in our favor.
His friend Botticelli was in Rome, his beloved master Verrocchio in Venice, working on an equestrian statue of Bartolomeo Collione.
So he went on studying by himself in all subjects that interested him.
But he was so poor, he finally had to seek the patronage of the Lord of Milan, Ludivico Sforza, most noble sire.
After many experiments, I would like to explain some of my secrets to Your Excellency.
I have the means to destroy any citadel or fortress.
I also possess all kinds of mortar, practical and portable.
As well as a number of weapons for naval combat.
I can build covered tanks, capable of penetrating enemy lines and destroying them with artillery.
And in peacetime, I could be most useful to you in architecture.
And in painting, I believe I am as capable as any other, if not more so.
Oh, if only I could read Plato, thought Leonardo.
They wouldn't treat me like a clown.
My, how time flies.
Good day to you. Fine day.
Pierrette, I was hoping you'd arrive. I want to show you something.
Over there. Come.
Where is it?
It's the time to strike. Now.
Will you?
Four to two.
Guard with your fancy ways, with your trains, and your sinful styles, and with the paint with which you hide your faces.
Repent, all of you!
Three to three. Even.
The year is 1490. Let's check up on our friend Leonardo, living in Milan at the house of Lodovico the Moor.
He has just made the acquaintance of the boy Saleno, who will become his adopted son.
That's the way to your house. Let's go, let's go, let's go.
The child was not always a joy to live with.
Books, lots of books, nothing but books.
Few of Leonardo's projects worked out, except for a portrait of Cecilia Gallerani, and another of a musician.
But there was to be one major undertaking, a gigantic equestrian statue of Francesco Sforza.
Before beginning it, however, Leonardo wanted to write a treatise on the horse,
and on the various ways of pouring bronze.
In the meantime, he amused himself with song, dance, and palace costumes.
Go fetch.
Yes, master.
My good master summons you for absolution.
In the year 1492, Lorenzo the Magnificent passed away without the blessing of Severo Nerola,
and was enjoying the height of his power.
Nothing here.
Down there.
Psalms for the poor, you.
Little children should be quick to obey, always, or Papa will be angry.
Nice necklace.
That's it. Cross it here, you old bag.
The joy you insist on seeking outside the Holy Word.
Oh, no, not that. That lovely work of art.
Repent, all of you sinners, there's time. Beware.
But Savonarola's triumph was short-lived.
His death ended the last lingering trace of the Middle Ages.
In that same year, 1498, Vasco da Gama discovered a passage to India.
Six years earlier, in 1492, the year of Lorenzo de' Medici's death,
the Catholic kings had completed their reconquest of Spain,
and their envoy, Christopher Columbus, had discovered America.
Alexander Borgia was proclaimed Pope,
and in France, construction began on the Chateau d'Amboise,
where Leonardo da Vinci would live out his last days.
Close of the century, Mantegna painted his famous Cristo Morto.
Leonardo, on a quick trip to Montaui, did a portrait of Isabella d'Este,
before returning to Florence.
Our friend has aged a bit, his beards grown white.
And how has he spent all these years?
Tinkering with everything as usual.
Geometry, mechanics, gravity.
The reflection of light, looms, hydraulics, ball bearings, pictograms, and many other things.
How easy it is to become knowledgeable, said he, with rather justifiable pride.
Da Vinci took up residence in the Monastery of St. Anne, to work on a newly commissioned painting.
Work is proceeding nicely.
Named as chief architect by Cesare Borgia, Leonardo draws up plans and inspects the work.
And here we'll level around.
There's the ideal site for the fortress.
Here it is guaranteed to be impenetrable.
By the time the master returned to Florence in 1503, he had become an important man.
His old friend Di Credi was now managing Verrocchio's studio.
In that same year, a young Polish student, Nicholas Copernicus, was graduated from Ferrara's university.
Leonardo da Vinci was now working on what would doubtless be a major painting, The Battle of Angiadi.
Oh, Trouble, a little on the spectacular side, battles, horses.
One, three. Wrong. Four to four. Pretty bad. I could just watch it fly. The wings glide. This inspiration is nature. Hey, easy, bud, easy. Hey, my bird. Oh, my good lord. Don't quite have it. Bash him to bits. Go on, bash him to bits. Those two beasts be about to bash him. Go on, go on. Go on. Go on. Go on.
Right, I will do the thing.
Five at five.
This guy's too clever.
This guy's too strong.
Huh?
I never would've thought that.
Master, may we see your project?
By your means, my friend, come look.
This fresco will go where?
On this wall.
And mine?
Hey, my project goes where?
And what will happen to my project?
Hey, you guys?
This wall has the best lighting, and I want it too.
I want it, Master, back home.
The young and gifted Michelangelo Buonarroti.
has a rather stormy character.
Such a pleasure to see you once more, friend.
It's worth celebrating, pal.
A toast for the sake of friendship.
Ching, ching.
Yeah, hmm.
Six to five.
Huh? Six up?
It may have been Da Vinci and Decreity
who inspired another budding painter, Raphael.
The two joined with Botticelli and the Perugian
to form a commission to determine
where young Michelangelo's latest statue
of the David should be placed.
Tend to see it here.
Hands off, you.
You prehistoric twig.
You must never speak of that tone to me.
Michelangelo and his statue in two years will be things in the past.
The neckline, yes, perhaps a bit much.
It's the face.
Ah, that face.
What a face.
Lovely face.
Not bad.
Interesting, that one.
One moment, please.
My respects, madam.
With your permission, may I ask you to smile?
That's enough, old man.
Ah, no, that's not right.
Out of my sight.
There, now, finally, I'm at peace.
There, that might be all right.
With a bit of luck, it may even fly.
Salai, come here.
Huh?
Look at my flying machine.
We'll be able to fly.
Just swing the arms and legs and...
So what?
It's you, son.
You'll be the first man to fly in history.
Who, me?
Flying?
Oh, no, Pop, not me.
One day you'll regret it, son.
Now, let's see.
Hmm, there.
Oh, my lord.
Lunderer, you're fired.
I'm looking for volunteers to fly my newest machine.
Works by means of pedals that make the wings up.
Wow, I'll volunteer.
Me too, when it comes to pedaling, I'm the greatest.
Ah, hmm, how embarrassing.
Well, the two of you then.
Up you go then, jump, it's easy.
And then...
You're gonna fly.
Are you afraid?
Yeah, I'm never scared.
I fear you might be too heavy.
You've had your warning.
He's flying, he's flying, he's flying.
Smile, I think I've got it.
I've got it, my cracky.
One day, in the Arno Valley,
Maestro's lively curiosities again aroused.
According to the Bible, fossils were deposited
in the mountains during the Great Flood.
If that were the case, thought Leonardo,
the shells should be scattered in the mud
any which way, not distributed in layers.
Let's dig along the bank.
It was dangerous to doubt the scriptures.
In Spain, it was a crime that led to the stake.
Yes, it's just as I thought.
With the fossils in layers like this,
their theory doesn't hold water.
Yeah. It's still quite damp. At this rate, it'll never dry.
Huh? What's all this?
Whatever is that for, my boy?
Just you wait and see.
And as for this masterpiece, you had to have the best wall.
And when Leonardo asked the gonfollier for his payment, he received it in worthless copper.
Deeply wounded, Leonardo decided to leave the city.
In 1506, in Rome, Vermont had just begun construction of the new St. Peter's Basilica.
It would take a century to complete.
1508, Michelangelo began work on the ceiling of the Sistine Chapel.
As for our friend Leonardo, he said,
my theories must be based on experience and not on another man's words.
So he experimented with various musical instruments,
mechanical drums, studies in geometry,
various types of machines, gear systems, watch mechanisms,
and a host of other things.
In 1510, Copernicus decided to wait not nine years as Pythagoras recommended,
but four times nine years before publishing his treatise entitled
on the revolutions of the celestial bodies.
And Leonardo?
He was pioneering in the fields of anatomy
and in every other direction that his insatiable curiosity took him.
The parachute, and then the bicycle,
propelled by a cogged wheel and chain.
It would take us four more centuries to produce another one like it.
Leonardo also wrote a treatise on painting,
and in his spare time, he painted.
Uh, close, but not quite.
1512, Michelangelo has just finished the Sistine Chapel ceiling.
Pretty good.
Raphael shows one of his latest compositions to Leonardo.
You see, Plato? Look closely, it's you. I use you as my model.
Vermont is working on St. Peter's. As for Da Vinci, he's working on his self-portrait.
Let me go out. Let me go with you. No, no, no, no. My boy. Yes?
Just you wait, I'll show you. Those who plot against the old master.
I've seen him profaning cadavers. He he he he he he he.
I've been seeing profaning cadavers. He's been seeing profaning cadavers.
Woo! Yeah, man.
...mixtures, I've seen it myself.
...rights weird feelings like a wizard or sorcerer.
1516, Leonardo had had enough.
In the same year, Michelangelo's Moses knew great success.
He accepted an invitation from King Francis I,
whose bravery and new artillery had just spelled victory at Mariano.
Aren't you going with us? As you wish.
And so Da Vinci went to France, without his adopted son.
i want that canvas his majesty the king is determined to possess this mona lisa no it is
out of the question it is not for sale you can return the gold to his majesty is that clear his
majesty will be displeased uh no no no no no no well then master i have brought all the gold in
the reserves there isn't any more away with all that oh now what will we do you sir return it to
me thank you your majesty because you love it so i promise that sire at my death it will be
But Leonardo would not enjoy his painting for long.
He died in 1519.
Cortes had reached Mexico.
Magellan was halfway around the world.
Charles V had just been crowned emperor.